[Music]
okay everyone i'm
really really excited today because i
have the honor of being joined by
madison iseman aka rain burrows in fear
of rain madison how you doing today
so great steve how are you i'm doing
really good um so
before we jump into this everyone who's
watching at home just make sure to watch
the movie first we're gonna talk
spoilers in this interview
so we're going to really kind of delve
into how crazy this film is but
what really i loved about this madison
was how powerful your performance was
it just really showed the acting chops
you really do
have and i was wondering watching it was
there any
other roles in film or tv that kind of
inspired your portrayal of rain
it's interesting because normally i
would say
yes but actually for this there wasn't
really anything in particular
that i drew from because really where
this came from obviously castile our
amazing director and i we did a bunch of
research that was kind of like the main
priority for everything um watched just
millions of videos
spoke with you know people in person and
uh there was a memoir
written by ellen sachs called the center
cannot hold which was sort of like
you know our bible throughout this whole
thing it kind of tells her journey from
a young woman to adulthood uh living
with schizophrenia
so i really use that book um as really
like my bible and
guidance throughout this whole thing so
no not really based on anyone just like
a mixture of
people's different experiences and what
i learned and gathered um
and you know hopefully we wanted to just
give like the most appropriate
performance portrayal that we possibly
could it was important to us
no wow that's that's a really
interesting answer and that's cool that
you kind of pulled from a book that's a
very unique style of like getting into a
character i like that a lot
so watching this also running through my
mind is how
heavy of a role this is and how dark of
a place you must have
gone to play rain now were you
in this mind of rain when the camera
wasn't rolling
and did you kind of how was it hard was
it to get out of that when the movie was
done filming
yeah i mean it's it's interesting um
obviously too
i i will never have any
idea what it is actually like to live
with schizophrenia
and and to be in those shoes um but i
mean obviously it was
very heavy material um a lot of days
were very exhausting
um but i i do i feel like i treat
characters and rolls almost like shoes
if that makes sense so like when i leave
for the day
i put on my shoes and then i come home
and i take them off so that way i'm kind
of able to just
unwind myself at home and i don't have
to bring anything
back with me um but it also helped
obviously we had just a
fantastic cast and so like harry connick
jr was just
such a jokester all day so it was nice
to kind of have like the levity of like
some lightness in between some of the
dark scenes
okay so that's that's great that you
actually have that and speaking of his
character who plays your father
in the film can you kind of elaborate on
the line that kind of stuck with me the
most that you say to him in your big
fight scene with him
when you said i'm not my sickness can
you kind of just go a little more what
that exactly means when rayne's saying
that
yeah i mean it's i think that's kind of
the whole stigma with
with mental illness and and
schizophrenia just as schizophrenia is
you know it's people who live with
schizophrenia they're they're ordinary
people
they put on their shoes in the morning
and they brush their teeth
and they have a future rain especially
like
it's so interesting to play a young
woman with schizophrenia
which i feel like is something that's
not often told from a perspective of you
know a 15 year old girl
um because she has a normal life and and
she goes to school and she has crushes
on boys and she gets in fights with her
dad
and she's thinking of college and like
people who live with schizophrenia
they're not their sickness they they
really aren't they
they have the world at their hands and
this is just a part of their
story and a part of their journey so
would you say that's
at the end of the day what this film is
mostly trying to say is there anything
else you would say this film's trying to
like get across as the main
message to the audience yeah i
definitely think that is
the main message is you know to
destigmatize and and to talk about
mental
illness and there's a scene actually
that castile wrote where reign is
actually explaining
what schizophrenia if her schizophrenia
is to caleb and i think it's just
something you never really see in films
like i feel like half the time they just
expect you to know
but i mean i hope someone who's watching
who doesn't have any idea
what schizophrenia is i hope they can
learn something um
you know more than anything i just think
we
there needs to be more representation in
film and i'm happy that this is like a
little stepping stone
into hopefully more no and that's a
great scene you just brought up because
that's when they're on the
she's on the bridge with caleb and she
says sorry for having schizophrenia he's
like would someone with diabetes say
sorry and that really did was effective
because it made me think about that and
i think
that really does serve to the purpose
like you're saying about getting rid of
the stigma of mental health and it was
really
effective um so i also want to ask
too because you're a little older than
your character of rain and now you're
kind of going back to like your high
school days did you find any
maybe scenes or moments that felt like
similar that you can relate to from
you know madison in her real life i mean
yeah like i
i love playing young it's so fun i part
of me just
wants to grow up um but i mean like
all those scenes with caleb especially
they were fun and like i love israel
he's so fantastic and
i just think it was so important to show
because you know it's
she's allowed she's allowed to have a
crush on a boy you know
and then obviously there's a whole
nother level of like is he real is he
not real
obviously but um yeah i i think
absolutely there's
she's she's a fun-loving girl and she
really just wants to be loved and
understood
yeah and you absolutely crush it here
and
it makes me really excited to see where
your career is actually to go
some exciting news about your career is
that you're going to be in i know what
you did last summer series on amazon
is there anything you can tell us about
it are you guys in production
are you guys like something you're
excited about
we're feeling right now right okay
okay i actually it's funny too i'm if
you
i i literally had a night shoot all last
night
i'm running on like an hour of sleep oh
man you are a trooper
doing it um no there's literally nothing
i can tell you we were sworn to secrecy
um i can tell you though that it is
going fantastic and i am
so excited um i cannot wait for us to
give
any sort of details because i'm like so
eager to talk about it but
no i can't say anything yet no but that
in itself is exciting it sounds like
it's gonna be
awesome i can't wait uh but while we
wait for that
everyone you must if you haven't already
watch fear of rain it's out today
available digitally on demand
and in select theaters and it's coming
to blue rain dvd on february 16th so you
have no excuse not to watch this film
and watch madison just take over and
show her real acting chops it's
an incredible film i'm so excited to
watch it and madison i'm so grateful for
talking to you today
thank you this was so great also i love
your uh
is that sharp objects in the back that
is
sharp objects love it great show great
show
great show you're uh isn't your girl
sydney sweeney in that one
awesome all right madison i hope to talk
to you in the future
yeah thank you take care stay safe you
too